-Our first guest tonight is
a Grammy-nominated
country-music star
who is also a coach on
the hit show "The Voice,"
which airs
Monday and Tuesday nights
here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
My team is full!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-[ Chanting ] Blake, Blake,
Blake, Blake, Blake, Blake!
-Let's go!
-Whoo!
It doesn't work.
It doesn't work anymore.
-Alright, Kelly Clarkson, it's
just me and you, sis.
-♪ Just you and I ♪
-You got quite the team there,
my old man.
-Old man?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Blake Shelton.
How are you, Blake?
-[ Laughs ] I'm doing good.
It's funny.
I haven't seen that part of
the show aired back yet,
and it's a lot of fun to see
a universal superstar
like Ariana Grande
call me an old man...
-Yeah.
-...on national television.
That's great for
my ego and confidence.
-Well, you've actually had
some ego issues over the years.
This isn't the first time
that Ariana Grande
has bumped up against your ego.
There was a time where
you guys put out albums
on the same weekend.
-[ Laughs ] I know.
Hey, I reminded her of that.
It was like -- That was in 2016,
and -- I don't know --
one of her huge albums came out,
and I had a project
I was putting out called
"If I'm Honest."
And we were so excited about it.
And I remember, the week
the album came out, I was like,
"What do you think
it's gonna --"
You know, you always
call your record label
and you're like, "What do you
think we're going to do?"
You know, you think it's going
to be number 1?"
And they're like,
"Well, you know, Ariana Grande's
album comes out this week.
But you could get
number 2, maybe."
So she took a dump on
those dreams, too.
By the way, great monologue.
I was sitting here with
my brother-in-law,
sitting off-screen,
and you were mentioning about
getting a sunburn
on your taint.
And then -- And it started
a whole conversation about
"What's the difference
in a chode and a taint?"
And we've been --
And it's really --
It's a great show, man,
because it causes
these conversations.
These conversations, you know?
-Yeah, we like to get people
talking about stuff
that they wouldn't
otherwise talk about.
-Yeah.
-You know, a brother-in-law,
of course,
is one of the many beneficiaries
of getting married,
and I want to
say congratulations,
because since
the last time we talked,
you officially
tied the knot with Gwen.
-We did, man.
We did it back in July.
And Gwen and I -- we agree that
if we're going to pull off
the ultimate publicity stunt,
which is what
this relationship is,
then we wanted to
follow through, man.
and go ahead and get married,
because, you know,
the next season of "The Voice"
was coming up,
and, you know,
we're team players for NBC.
Which I am -- By the way,
I am your boss now.
-You are my boss, deservedly so.
I want to just say, like,
this is a photo --
She is a beautiful bride.
You are also in this picture.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what
I love about that picture?
Is that her arm is perfectly
placed to drop --
to block my
double chin right there.
-That's true love right there.
-You can't see the pelican chin
hanging down as much.
-You were married by
Carson Daly.
Did you think, 20 years ago,
the host of "TRL"
would be the guy
helping you tie the knot?
-Man, I tell you what.
The way he handled those
wet-T-shirt contests
back in the day when
he was hosting those
spring-break specials,
we knew --
we knew he had to be
the guy for us.
-'Cause those things can get
pretty hairy.
If he can keep his cool there,
you know,
he is the right guy
for your big day.
-He was -- I don't know
who was more excited.
When we called Carson -- I mean,
we were a little bit nervous
to even ask him
because the guy's so --
I mean, he's so busy.
I don't even know how he does --
Literally, he has a radio show.
He has the "Today" show.
He has "The Voice."
And he used to have a show that
came on, you know,
after -- I guess, what,
two shows after your show.
You know what I mean?
Like when nobody was watching.
You know what I'm saying?
Which is why
you probably didn't know
he doesn't have
that anymore, but --
-Now we just throw it to
the tumbleweeds.
-And it was like, you know,
how are you
going to ask him
to do this thing?
But he jumped on
the opportunity,
and he ended up staying there
with his family
for a few days with us.
It was awesome. It really was.
-So, this is interesting.
So when I got married, you know,
we wrote our own vows.
And I -- You know, being
somebody who writes comedy,
I found that pressure of, like,
wanting to be funny.
You wrote a song
for your wedding.
Did you feel the
same pressure to, actually,
do a song up to your standard?
-Well, I didn't feel pressure
because she didn't know
I was going to do it.
So I felt like, "You know,
there's really no bar,
you know, to set right here.
But we agreed that
we were going to --
And it was Carson's idea
that we should write our own,
you know, vows or whatever.
I have this piece to say
before we say "I do,"
and Gwen has always -- She is
constantly on my ass about
I should be writing more songs.
"How come you
don't write more songs?"
You know?
And I have gotten lazy
about it over the years.
And so I decided,
"Well, you know, I'll step up
and come up with something,"
and so I did.
And we're putting it on --
I'm putting out a deluxe version
of this record that
we have out now,
and we're going to
put it on there.
And so I'm excited.
I'm excited for people to
hear it, you know?
A lot of people ask me about it
since they found out
that I did that, and so I'm --
we're excited about it.
I want people to hear it.
I mean, my God,
I married Gwen Stefani.
I want all -- I want everybody
to hear that.
I mean, that's
the ultimate bragging rights.
-It's really good.
Did you -- I'm curious.
When you were performing it
at the wedding,
was it an eye-contact situation?
Were you looking right at her
as you were doing the song?
-I did, I did.
I had rehearsed it
so many times just, you know,
in the bathroom or when we
weren't together or whatever
that I really had it down,
you know?
The only thing I was concerned
about was breaking the barstool
that they had for me to sit on.
That was literally something
that was in my mind like,
"Oh, wouldn't that be great
if I sat on this thing, and..."
But I didn't. I made it through.
-I'm very glad to hear this.
This is -- You hit
a milestone, as well.
The 20-year anniversary of,
I guess,
your first big hit, "Austin."
-That's right.
-That was
the mulleted Blake Shelton,
who was not hanging with
Carson Daly back in the day.
-Let me tell you something, man.
That mullet was underrated.
And I think it should come back.
I don't know about -- Did you
ever have a mullet or --
Is this as long as your hair's
ever been, right now?
-This -- No, back in college,
it was very long.
I could put it
in a ponytail in college.
-But no mullet.
-No mullet, no.
-Yeah. Well,
you missed out, buddy.
You missed out on
all the action.
Let me tell you.
-You're coming up on
500 episodes of "The Voice."
This is the 21st season.
It's been about 10 years now.
And you get audiences
back after some time away.
It just must be great to have
live audiences back
for a show like that.
-We had them for the
blind auditions this season,
and that's the first time in --
I guess, we went two seasons
without an audience,
which was --
You know, it wasn't fun.
It's not the same, you know?
It's mostly for the people
who are auditioning,
because, for us coaches,
it's not about
the audience, you know?
In fact, sometimes, it's
a distraction for us coaches.
But it's not as fun for,
I don't think,
the contestants not to have that
immediate feedback, you know?
Especially if somebody doesn't
make it on to the show,
you know, at least
they get the sendoff like,
"You know, it will be okay."
You know, but nothing's worse
than when you didn't make it
and you have to have
that silent, you know,
walk off the stage.
It was just -- It's horrifying.
And so having the audience
back this season --
it just feels so much better.
It's music, you know?
And so you want people
to be there.
-And, as the winningest coach,
how confident do you feel --
-Oh, you're talking about me.
Oh, you're talking about me
when you say that.
Yeah. Yeah.
-How confident are
you right now, Blake?
-Well, you know --
Listen, Ariana is a --
She's a super-talented,
very sweet human being.
I -- My feeling is,
she's going to suck as a coach.
-Yeah.
-And Kelly Clarkson --
I think her --
it's kind of
fizzled out, you know?
Just too -- There's too much
Kelly on TV.
I joke that NBC
is "Nothing But Clarkson."
People are tired of her.
People are sick
and tired of her.
-Yeah.
-And with John Legend, he's just
so high all the time,
I don't even know if he knows
he's on TV, you know?
And so I feel like this year's
going to be a gimme for me,
and I'm excited about it.
-Well, it's always great
to have you here.
I would love -- If you could
do some research on
the difference between
taint and chode,
and we'll talk about it
next time you're on.
-I will. We'll do that.
He's Googling it right now.
We're looking at pictures.
We can tell by the pictures.
-Hey, all the best, Blake.
It's always great to see you.
-Thank you, buddy.
-"The Voice" airs Monday
and Tuesday nights here on NBC.